[Music]
LT cuts interior Dorothy Chandler
Pavilion tension mounts on Oscar night
is too popular young actors prepare to
open the next envelope anxious audience
welcomes Matt Dillon the star of The
Outsiders and Tex and Kristy McNichol
the star of the rest of the country
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there are two categories for which short
subjects live and animated I'll take the
live you're more animating thank you for
the best achievement in an animated
short film the nominees are the great
kognito Will Vinton producer snowman
produced by John Coates tango the
producer is zu big noob ribbed ski sky
something young globe and the winner is
tango jib new ski
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
son of needs will convey academic
distinguished members of the Academy
ladies and gentlemen w having krotkiy
I know Roberto good I made a short film
so I will speak very short Bardo
rasatala I feel honored to receive this
award
Amazo I am dreaming chickadees that
someday but no Garcia aye Gomez up Shiva
yatra loser
I will speak longer from this place
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we have important message
very Slavic custom we are very warm
people
Corrado film of trebiciano film fatih
Terim gandhi and on the occasion of the
film like Gandhi Ola who viventia oh
sorry darkness which will portray let
Valenza and solidarity thank you thank
you
your turn again for best achievement in
a live action short film the nominees
are ballet robotic Bob Rogers and
producer a shocking accident fifteen
Ostreicher producer the silence booth by
Michael - shi Wu ji Qing yo and Joseph
Benson split cherry tree produced by
Jane Saunders shred
[ __ ] red knee by star Andrew Perkins
producer and the winner is a shocking
accident just to finish
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a tremendous honor I'm
tremendously pleased to be here tonight
I would like to thank the Academy for
their appreciation of our work I would
like to thank Graham Greene for the
inspiration with his story and for
supporting our project from the outset I
would like to thank our backers the
national film finance corporation and
Virgin films and they had great faith in
us and I would like to thank our cast
and prove who had such fantastic esque
expertise and professionalism and I
would like to thank I would like to
thank James Scott the most important
person who's provided the magic touch
thank you thank you
[Applause]
you